hallo leute müssen halt auf zwei dinge
achten erstens dass diese teile bleiben
wo sie sind und zweitens dass wir nicht
betrunken werden eine aufgabe ist sehr
einfach raten welche allerdings wieder
eure mal wann und willkommen zu einem
neuen test es heute passe ich gar nicht
dass ich dieses video dreh dich mal
wieder so ein testvideo wo ich einfach
nur neugierig bin ich will einfach nur
wissen will
ihr habt dem titel wie immer gelesen ich
teste heute alkohol mit 0 prozent
alkohol anscheinend bist du draußen eine
welt in der es wodka gin whisky & co
ohne alkohol gibt ist das alles nur ein
großer betrug oder steckt da doch ein
guter geschmack hinter events
herausfinden
ich ziehe irgendwas drüber und so können
sich jetzt alle zuschauer auf die
wichtigen dinge konzentrieren eingeholt
und probieren jetzt mal womit fangen wir
an wir starten mit chardonnay wenn ihr
meinen weißwein test gesehen habt wisst
ihr dass ich jetzt ein kleiner weißwein
experte bin aber einen alkoholfreien
weißwein werde ich fänd's klasse wenn
alkoholfrei alkohol alkohol einsetzen
kann dann kann alkoholfreie alkohol
alkohol setzen
der gedanke hoch absolut wie bei 0,5
prozent
das kriegen würde würde ich sagen ja das
ist mein gott ich habe irgendwie
erwartet traubensaft zu trinken weil was
ist wein wein ist traubensaft aber es
schmeckt nach weißwein okay ich bin sehr
gespannt auf die anderen produkte okay
das ist zeit für einen richtig guten
whiskey der wissen whisky nach alkohol
ich trink ich hab ja wirklich 0 prozent
also das soll whisky sein whisky kennt
man aus filmen die sehr dramatisch sind
wurde an die hauptcharaktere sowas sagen
wie ich hätte
mein kind beschützen können es riecht
wie whisky es hat mich diesen beißenden
geruch besteht dass meine aber es riecht
nach whiskey muss leute okay der auf
mich fertig er schmeckt wirklich wie
whisky ich bin kein whisky kenner wenn
man ein bisschen kenner ist würde man
sagen oh mein gott das ist eine blöde
und ich bin ja ein bisschen kleiner aber
ich weiß ja wie whisky schmeckt und das
schmeckt wie es gilt das einzige was
fehlt ist dieser brennende geschmack auf
der zunge der alkohol schmeckt einfach
den whisky geschmack an ich muss sagen
so pur finde ich das nicht lecker
stellt euch mal vor man macht eine party
und sagt seinen freunden nichts und hat
überall alkoholfreien alkohol und das
schmeckt also wenn man daraus dass die
kohle machen würde würde man denken ist
whisky cola also werden alle auf placebo
betrunken und am ende des abends zu
werden alle keinen tropfen alkohol um
alle sind so
nutzen wir alle wieder nüchtern
worldwide magic unser nächstes wird
empfohlen mit ginger beer und zwar ist
es also rum aber keine ruhe kommt aus
kopenhagen und hat unter 0,5 prozent
alkohol dass dinge sich hatte die sachen
in der tiefkühl und wenn ich alkohol in
den tiefkühler machen passiert nix was
alkohol ist das fried nicht so schnell
aber das ist ja keine so alles ein
bisschen angefroren okay also es wird
empfohlen warum und wie chillen ist mit
ginger beer auf und schon haben wir
einen kopf des tiers my friends also das
nächste mal im kino mal wieder ein
zuviel hat wenn ich ihm einfach das
geben verrückt also ja ich würd ich
würde dem gering hier auf 10 von 10
geben dass also ich bin einfach nur
gerade absolut schockierend begeistert
darüber dass ist ohne alkohol ist vor
allem ich habe gerade im trinken kann
das machen und die betrunken auf dem
scharf machen wir weiter mit wodka also
noch wodka 0 prozent alkohol
the spirit nach alkohol
laut kompromiss und jetzt falls ihr noch
nicht in dem alter seit dass ihr das
schon mal getrunken habt lebst der
geruch von wodka haut schon ziemlich gut
rein es liegt so als ob es hier die
nasenhaare weg bringen könnte und ich
muss mal ganz kurz meinen freund sein
verletzter sein soll
wir waren jetzt beim geruch und
lübeck hat auch keine 40 prozent t
shirts auf wort gab
ich habe das gefühl auch wenn da kein
ipod drin ist wird es trotzdem nicht
besser schmecken also kurz leute was
habe ich erwartet und warum ich gerade
bekommen ist brennt ein bisschen wie
wodka ist es aber auch so wie wodka gut
vielleicht wenn man zwischen würde auch
nur vielleicht moment immissions mal
kommen ein versuchslabor erstes
experiment einen drink damit machen
fischer reporter und ein bisschen wild
berry und die frage schmeckt das wie ein
richtiger wodka döring nein
das fällt definitiv durch und wenn wir
schon mal bei krassen spirituosen sind
kommen wir jetzt zu wenig hohl freier
kind schnell wie das ist ja alles
alkoholfreies und bei den könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass es klappt denn das hat
ein bisschen mehr da sind so kräuter
drin der geruchstest und höher
woran erinnert mich das an badesalz am
kräuterbad wenn man krank ist und sich
dann dieses grüne zeug ins wasser macht
und besuche ich dann am ende das wasser
schmeckt sowie das kräuter wasser riecht
hier machen wir uns jetzt ein dschinn
moscow mule heißt es jetzt nach drinnen
mit gender ein sondern ist immer noch
das kreuz fühlt sich vielleicht für uns
dass du an und das erste mal alkohol
trinkt wie für mich jetzt
diese pläne zu trinken aber warum hört
man da nicht auf den alkohol zu trinken
könnte es gesellschaftlicher druck seien
die ernst nicht in der gruppe dazu zu
gehören immerhin viermal so fahre jetzt
mal gesagt lasst euch die zum trinken
animiert ich trinke sonst kein rotwein
den rotwein macht mir einen dicken
schädel ich krieg migräne oder frauen
und mir geht es einmal nicht gut
nichtsdestotrotz habe ich dem grundwein
auch ausgesucht da wir wollen uns ja
durch testen und hat möglich 0% und es
ist nicht mehr los ich finde es schön
wie sie das durchziehen das auch so
richtig schön aussehen zu lassen als ob
es ein richtiger rotwein wäre und dann
lassen wir einfach den alkohol raus es
riecht wie rotwein alkoholfreier wein
funktioniert wirklich gut glaube ich ok
chef anderen wein ist kein traum sei
dementierte cent alkoholisiertes traum
getränk zucker konservierungsmittel
schwefeldioxid ich bin kein rotwein fan
aber das ist einfach es ist rotwein wenn
man rotwein vermisst oder dann wirklich
sagt er auch auf ein bisschen mehr
verzichten und sagen
muss ich jeden angetrunken sein aber ich
mag mein glas wein am abend so gut das
nächste was wir probieren es ein model
und zwar ein motto alkoholfrei natürlich
gespannt weil diese fertig cocktails die
man so unterwegs kaufen kann schmecken
ja eh schon immer nicht so gut
nicht wirklich aber stell dich mal vor
euch stehen ist irgendwo ein werde ich
nach so einer dachterrasse party und
trinkt hier mein motto
ja ja das geht das geht richtig gut rein
gut empfehlung von vanessa natürlich
dass dieser klassiker nicht fehlen ein
gutes krombacher radler alkoholfrei der
bekannteste alkoholischen drink den es
alkoholfrei gibt würde ich nicht noch
mal trinken ich weiß dass von heineken
also ist keine radlader von einigen das
alkoholfreie bier das schmeckt mir
wirklich gut also darf ich auch immer
begeistert und so dass alkoholfreies
bier kann man einfach weil das ist schon
so in der gesellschaft angekommen leute
ihr habt das bis zum ende des videos
geschafft dafür belohne ich euch mit
einem v6
[Musik]
mensch 0 prozent alkohol aber 100
prozent spaß ist mein neues kanal
konzept aber das recht auf jeden fall
zarter als ich sonst prosecco kennt die
leute hier muss es ist anders als beim
weißwein man schmeckt es da was faul ist
aber es schmeckt sehr lecker man sich
sagen schmeckt ein bisschen wie so hugo
ganz ehrlich ich find prosecco sekt
schmeckt immer soja und stößt sogar mit
ahnen und ist so jemand dann ist man
aber auch froh wenn man sein kleines
glas ausgetrunken hat dass leute gönne
ich mir so dass aus einem video mein
fazit ist absolute empfehlung sich mal
durch non alkoholische alkoholische
getränke zu probieren
man kann die finger von wodka gin lassen
das war jetzt wirklich ein griff ins klo
warum whisky weißwein rotwein hotels tv
klar und das ausschalten
ihr könnt ja nicht mitbringen also wir
können schon mal das abstreiten